one of the key tasks that Russo is
engaging in throughout the discourse is
trying to explain to us the developments
that human beings must have gone through
in order to reach the civilized state
that we find ourselves in today and so
he's going to begin by trying to strip
away all of the things that are
achievements that we take for granted
these great points of change along the
way now
passions are something that are going to
develop from the the original state that
human beings are in we're like other
animals they have passions or emotions
or drives all the way to the present
where we have a much wider range of
passions than we originally started out
with the emotional makeup the
effectivity of human beings has
developed the sensibilities of human
beings have developed over time you
could say but some of these other things
we might just take for granted if we're
thinking about projecting people into
the state of nature and Rousseau says we
have to be very careful about that
thought for example the primitive human
beings that we're talking about they
possess a ability to reason an ability
to think but they're not exercising it
in the same way that we are and they
don't have the same tools you might say
those have to gradually bit by bit by
bit become part of our inheritance that
we pass on and much of that is
attributable to the interconnection
between thought and language later on
then we discuss property and he talks
about that as a first revolution and
then we talk about a second revolution
with metallurgy and agriculture now
notice that long before we get to things
like agriculture or metallurgy or even a
conception of property as such we're
talking about human beings developing
the
most fundamental instruments that set
them apart from the other animals
thought and language we've talked about
the human being in the state of nature
using their body as an instrument sort
of the universal instrument for all
sorts of tasks language allows us to do
that as well and so does thinking all of
these by the way are coming out of the
human capacity or as your so it said
self-improvement now we begin by talking
about our passions and Rousseau says
that when we're thinking about human
beings in the state of nature that is
where we need to begin we we don't begin
with complex thoughts as a matter of
fact first we feel things there we go
and then we begin to think about them so
he says first we have passions that
include desire fear our will our free
will the ability to say yes to say no to
things and from those we're going to get
other things we're going to get thoughts
how does that can happen
well we eventually begin to develop
knowledge we desire something we pursue
it we put it into our models like little
babies tastes good we eat it
we don't get sick now we actually know
we can keep eating that thing we do the
same thing a little with something else
we have an adverse reaction
now maybe we actually feel a sense of
fear when we see that that red berry on
the bush that we shouldn't have eaten
because it made us have nausea
or you know gave us elucidation x' or
something along those lines it's by
having desire and fear for things that
we end up coming to knowledge and the
knowledge in turn can feed into more
desires and fears and all of this
promotes our capacities for thinking
this doesn't happen all at once this
happens
bit by bit by bit in one individual
another individual over time over
generations I'm not even going to say
that there's an observable difference
between one generation and the next
necessarily in the grand historical
sweep of things but there is a progress
human beings acquire a greater stock of
ideas and they end up having greater
desires and greater fears a wider range
thereby and that's part of what elevates
us outside of the realm of just instinct
just passions just desires just fears
the ability to form conceptions of
things but as Rousseau is going to say
one of the things that we have to think
about is the fact that our thinking
processes are actually dependent upon
language
so unless language has developed we're
not going to be able to think that funny
says let us let me consider how many
ideas we owe to the use of speech how
far grammar exercises the understanding
and facilitates its operations this may
not be something that you think about
very much but if you pay close attention
to how you may actually think about
things you do so in large part through
the instrumentality of language and if
you didn't understand human languages
you would not have the range of thoughts
that are available to you which you
simply take for granted because it's
such a you know baseline part of what
what we have become that's not something
that these early human beings can simply
take for granted though says let us
reflect upon the inconceivable pains and
the infinite space of time that the
first invention of languages must have
cost how did language come into being
what is the actual origin point of that
Rousseau's I don't have an answer other
people have tried to offer answers for
where language came from they've tried
to provide some sort of account but
those are all subject to a number of
different difficulties before you can
invent language you actually need to
have language because how else could you
articulate to yourself the fact that you
need to communicate with somebody else
that's one difficulty right there he
says the main difficulty how language
can become necessary as there was no
communication among men no need for any
we can either conceive the necessity nor
the possibility of this invention if it
was not somehow indispensable yeah some
people want to say he says that language
arose from the the relationship between
parents and children and so it came out
of human need because parents would you
know hear their children expressing
certain things like crying for example
you know if you're a parent you can
start to sense of difference if you're
paying close attention between different
kinds of crying at certain times and
other times it's just a cacophonous
noise that is set up to make us you know
like go into action as matter of fact a
baby crying you know there's one of the
worst noises researchers have found you
know for human beings they have to hear
so it's it's not going to be that he
says if it was that then every single
trouble would be making up its own
language and the language is basically
died out with that child
that's not language if you think about
what language actually is language is
communication requires that you and I
and other people be on the same page so
to speak that we actually share some
something in common
that when we use words even if they're
the same words the same signs the same
sounds then you need to mean more or
less the same thing when you hear the
word as when I'm speaking the word or
else we don't actually have a language
now it's difficult to explain how that
is going to come out he says let's
actually just say the first difficulty
where language came from let's say
that's taken care of what could we say
about primitive language let's that he
says let us for a moment then take
ourselves as being on this side of the
vast space which must lie between a pure
state of nature and that in which
languages have become necessary let's
inquire how they could first become
established and here we have a paradox
here we have a problem because it looks
like language is required for thought
but thought is also required for
language now one way that you can
actually deal with this problem is by
saying that we start out with very crude
language underdeveloped language and
that you know arises out of some sort of
need we don't know that we're and that
provokes greater development thoughts
and that in turn provokes or ristic
development and then that in turn
provokes still better thoughts and what
we have in this I've only got four
stages here but imagine you know
thousands and thousands of stages spread
out over a vast array of time in which
language is becoming more articulate and
thought is also likewise becoming more
articulate the two of them are slowly
reinforcing and building upon each other
Rousseau is going to begin with you know
a few ideas that other people have had
he says maybe language came about from a
simple cry of nature may be the most
crude language was just men going yeah
you know like they see a same
Tiger you know where they see the deer
and they know that deer tastes good and
they're like mmm that sort of thing
right and he says at first you know
maybe that was the case but that doesn't
really explain anything that that won't
work you know why because that's not the
common situation in life you're not
looking at deer or saber-toothed tiger
most of the time you're actually doing
other stuff so let's let's take is
another possibility maybe the way it
began was human beings start you know
making sounds and making gestures
pointing at things like you know of
course in the state of nature they're
not there they don't chalk but you know
somebody goes blah blah blah right now
that means truck or at least this piece
of chalk and the other guy picks it up
and says blah blah blah and eventually
they start to realize that when it gets
dark you can't really see people
pointing at things or doing whatever
other gestures they might be doing and
so they start to substitute words for
that what we're doing is we're moving
from you know very crude language is
more sophisticated language by doing
that but we're so has some other really
interesting speculations about what
language could have been like at that
time he says that words would have to
have a much more extensive signification
so that one word would substitute for an
entire proposition what do we mean when
we talk about a proposition this is
something that we probably need to spell
out a little bit so that there's there's
no one clarity about this the most basic
propositions are subject plus verb or
you can say subject and predicate right
so I eat notice that what we've got
there is two different signs I meaning
me eat I won't pantomime the gesture of
eating but you know you get the idea
maybe in primitive language they would
just say eat it
or maybe the word for eat would be just
the word for the most common kind of
well maybe the word for food would be
the most common kind of food like in
Mandarin Chinese to eat an idiom for
that is you know cheer fun fun is rice
but you know sure if I'm can just mean
eat food what we're doing there is we're
simplifying Rousseau says that something
like that must have taken place except
at the level where each word would mean
a whole proposition probably a whole
bunch of things at the same time he also
thinks that each object would get named
as a particular object so instead of
having subjects we would really just
have names so drag tie now somebody
else's tie might be called charlie
or if we have separate pieces of char
what we're so is saying is that these
would not be originally one two three
four five six six pieces of chalk all
the same substance this could be chalk
this could be awk
this could be dooga doo this could be
blah blah blah this could be nose this
could be kitten or any any other extra
combination there wasn't a sense where
these are all grasped as being the same
kind of thing you know why because in
order to do that you have to have a term
that can mean multiple things that can
stand in for it like eating for example
when I eat today it's the same action of
eating even though I'm eating something
different as the action of eating
yesterday or when you eat we use these
general terms for basic concepts and as
human beings in civilized society we
just take it for granted that that's the
way the human mind works but Russo's
point is no that's a hard one
achievement that took a long time to
acquire says general ideas can't be
introduced into the mind without the
assistance of the words nor can the
understanding seize upon them without
the use of propositions this
one reason why animals can't form such
ideas or ever acquire the capacity for
self-improvement which depends upon them
so notice now this capacity for
self-improvement has now been connected
to language and thought it is dependent
in its exercise upon language and
thought so the more that language and
thought become developed the greater the
capacity for self improvement for
changing the human condition from what
it originally is from moving away from
the cure of the animal to the cultural
the more that becomes possible I'm not
going to talk much about the development
of property because you know Rousseau
discusses that in other places but the
basic conception is that by living in in
certain places together we acquire this
conception of this being mine and that
being yours keep your hands off of my
stuff because that's what it means for
it to be mine
and this also here's the important part
this is something that's articulated by
thought and language if we look at you
know words like mine or in Latin Mayim
and two of mine and yours
you can only articulate those concepts
if you have words for them that is an
advance that is a development now
Rousseau talks about human beings
associating into essentially tribal
societies developing new passions I'm
actually going to skip over the
development of those new passions but he
ends up talking about the development of
a state in which we have property
languages becoming quite complex
societies becoming quite complex
thinking is going on he says as ideas
and feelings succeeded one another in
heart and head were brought into play
men continued to lay aside their
original wildness their private
connections become more intimate as
their limits extended they began to
consider other people they have a
conception of themselves as living
within a society as being a person of
this tribe as being a person of this
group and morality comes on the scene
and now we get to the great revolution
that occurs that will take us from a
kind of you know primitive tribal
society into early ancient fully well
not fully developed but you know fully
developing societies he says metallurgy
and agriculture were the two arts which
produce this great revolution and
Rousseau has a very equivocal attitude
towards metallurgy and agriculture
he says the poet's tell us it was gold
and silver that for a civilized man and
ruined humanity but really it was corn
or wheat or whatever grain you have and
iron he says thus thus both were unknown
to the savages of America who for that
reason are still sandwich of course
we're so is off-base about that because
we know they were vast agricultural
civilizations of the Americas but he
even say the same thing about them I'd
say so much the worse for that they're
better off if they're these
hunter-gatherers living in fairly you
know primitive bands where they they are
fairly happy agricultural societies are
more unhappy according to Rousseau
societies in which metallurgy exists are
more unhappy and here we have is this
paradoxical dynamic where progress or
human improvement which is supposed to
lead to greater human happiness actually
leads to greater human misery instead
now why would it do that well because it
complicates things and it changes our
nature it introduces all sorts of new
inequalities so he says we'll talk about
that in a moment
think about how I are working and
agriculture come about says just like
with language it's difficult to
conjecture how fit how people first came
to know and use iron it's not the sort
of thing that you would sort of just
think of well I'm gonna dig down there
and get some or if you understand what's
involved in iron working or metalworking
in general what you have to get is or
and then you have to heat it up and get
the metal to come out then you have to
form it so he says we have the less
reason to suppose this discovery the the
effect of any accidental fire we only
find these sort of things in the ground
it looks like Nature had taken pains to
keep that fatal secret from us so we
have to assume something like the
extraordinary accident of some volcano
which is ejecting metallic substances
already in fusion and then that
suggested to the spectators the idea of
imitating that and he says agriculture
the principles of it we're lowering
known before they were put into practice
that's a little bit easier to wrap our
head around human beings would eat
things that they would come into contact
with and a lot of those things had seeds
and they found that well if you leave
those seeds on the ground that same sort
of thing pops up and then maybe if you
keep doing that over and over again you
know you can be sure that you're gonna
find that great berry patch or you're
gonna find that you know wild chick pea
patch chickpeas are one of the early
domesticated things - or cucumbers
probably the point about early cucumbers
were very small but people would eat
them so he says um when they grew more
industrious it is natural to believe
that they began with the help of a few
sharp stones and pointed sticks to
cultivate a few vegetables or roots
around their huts and it was long before
they knew how to prepare corn grain or
were provided with the instruments
necessary for raising it in any large
quantity these two things go together as
well don't they the metallurgy
agriculture reinforce each other of
course you can have Stone Age implements
and
you know do agriculture but it's a lot
easier when you actually have bronze let
alone iron and you can begin to do
things like plow ground or carry water
in in containers and irrigate when you
can do when you can change the face of
the earth and metallurgy in its own turn
demands that you have people who are
devoted to providing food if you want to
have a Smith that Smith has to be fed
those workers the miners who are digging
out the or the people who are refining
it they all have to be fed so metallurgy
both makes agriculture more possible and
demands an intensification of
Agriculture all of these processes are
leading to a state of greater and
greater and more complex civilization so
he says the invention of the other arts
motifs must have been necessary to
compel mankind to apply themselves to
agriculture no sooner were artificers
wanted to smelt and forge iron others
were required to maintain them the more
hands that were employed in
manufacturers the fewer that were left
to provide for the common substance so
by this means the arts of husbandry and
agriculture were established on the one
hand and the art of working metals and
multiplying their uses on the other
we're not just talking about
metalworking as making metal things
we're talking here about technology so
we're talking about the annotation of
things from the natural environment to
create artificial things so he says the
cultivation of the earth necessarily
brought about its distribution property
once recognized gave rise to the first
rules of justice for to secure to each
man his own it had to be possible for
each to have something and here we see
that we're now arrived at a state of
quite complex society where language and
thought can mimic what's going on with
property with metallurgy with
agriculture we're now looking at the
kinds of civilizations that we see
in history